there's no doubt that avengers end game
was one of the most successful superhero
films of all time wrapping up so many
different character arcs that spread
over a decade of movies
there's one scene near the end of the
film though that's led fans to develop a
crazy theory that captain america steve
rogers is actually mr rogers welcome
back everyone to stream in the galaxy my
name is rocket riley and today we're
going to be talking about the fan theory
that the mcu's captain america is mr
rogers but before we get started if
you're new to the channel please hit the
subscribe button and click the bell icon
to be notified when we upload a new
video now avengers endgame saw the final
chapter of several different marvel
characters stories including iron man
black widow and captain america the mcu
saga started with tony stark a
self-centered billionaire who grew into
a father willing to sacrifice everything
for the greater good as iron man
black widow or natasha romanov also
sacrificed herself to help get the soul
stone and to defeat thanos
one of the craziest changes though
happened in some of the final scenes of
the movie steve rogers was tasked with
returning the infinity stones to their
own timelines in order to prevent a
complete collapse in the multiverse and
strands of time held in place by the tva
and the sorcerer supreme doctor strange
some of what steve did when he went back
in time could be seen as a contributing
factor to the cataclysmic events that'll
be shown in spider-man no way home and
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness
fans have even come up with a movie idea
for marvel studios titled captain
america the last mission where he has to
overcome obstacles to return the
infinity stones before settling down
with peggy carter this film could also
give some more clarity into how steve
could actually become fred rogers
when steve went back in time using the
pym particles we assumed that he placed
the infinity stones back in their
respective timelines before traveling to
the 1940s to live with his one true love
peggy
we even see a scene at the end of
avengers end game of steve dancing
slowly with peggy finally settling down
after years of war and fighting other
people's battles this fan theory
suggests that due to his natural desire
to do good and his near perfect moral
compass steve wasn't able to just stay
at home raising his family i don't see
him being able to go to work in a 9-5
normal job after saving the world
countless times and facing the threats
he's had to throughout his career
instead he had to go out and do
something meaningful with his life
spreading positivity in the world
changing his first name to fred but
keeping his surname rogers in the scene
where steve gives the iconic shield and
mantle of the captain america name to
sam wilson he doesn't tell sam about his
life he just says
this is beautiful
this certainly leaves his life from the
1940s to the present day up to
interpretation
it seems as if he's almost purposely not
telling sam about his past in order to
cover up his true identity steve wanted
to share his wisdom and ideals with the
rest of the world so he became the
unforgettable mr rogers hosting the
educational children's television show
mr rogers neighborhood which ran from
1968 to 2001.
steve now named fred decided to live the
life that was taken away from him when
he sacrificed it all in the first
captain america film
not only is this something steve has
wanted his whole life it's something he
deserves after all he's given to the
world and the best part is he's not done
giving to the world he continues to
share kindness and wholesome messages to
children around the world all while
fulfilling his dream of being with peggy
once again
this theory is pretty believable because
we know how good-natured steve rogers is
and we know how willing he is to help
people in need steve held grief
counseling sessions following the snap
and avengers end game using his years of
wisdom to help give people clarity and
closure in their lives this just shows
how steve wanted to help spread
positivity and to change people's lives
for the better just as mr rogers did
with his television show
the two also look quite similar with
almost identical hairstyles and skin
tones the resemblance is pretty uncanny
between the two of them the only issue
in the theory is that steve was born in
1918 and fred was born in 1928. one
could probably say that cap seemed to
age more slowly because of the super
soldier serum so he looked like he might
have been born in 1928 and so he just
fudged some medical records when he
changed his name
it's hard to think of any other flaws in
this theory that can't be fixed with
just a bit of extra storytelling
if steve did actually become fred rogers
when he stayed back in the 40s he only
did so because he believed he could make
a greater impact on people by doing so
rather than by fighting wars although
captain america did have a knack for
beating all odds and winning against
powerful global threats his superhuman
capabilities have always come second to
the reason he was actually chosen for
the super soldier program in the first
place
get away
get back
[Music]
is this a test
both captain america and mr rogers hold
a special place in many people's hearts
and the thought of them being the same
person in an alternate reality gives a
certain level of closure to the
character of steve rogers that we didn't
really get an avengers end game plus
it's fun to think of kind mr rogers
having superhuman strength and access to
thor's hammer mjolnir just thinking of
the two individuals being the same
person brings a smile to my face and i
hope to see more wholesome theories like
this in the future
well that's gonna be everything from us
today on the captain america mr rogers
theory if you enjoyed the video please
hit the like button and don't forget to
subscribe for more great content what
are your thoughts about this theory are
there any other details which further
prove its truth drop your thoughts in
the comment section below
from everyone here at stream of the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching